We have a voicemail number that you can call
absolutely anytime you want. The number is
two one nine two David P.. Here's
a question about our old friend,
Rudy Giuliani. Take a listen to this.
Hi, this is Jim from Canada. Yeah. And I was
wondering, I was watching one of your old episodes
about Rudy Giuliani right back a year ago. And I
was wondering, have you heard what happened to him
lately? I mean, last time I heard about a couple
of months ago, he was facing the possibility
of being disbarred or whatever from, you know,
from a legal practice. Yeah. He was going to
have his lawyers license revoked or taken away.
I didn't hear any news about Rudy lately. Just
curious. Have a good day. Keep up the good work.
So there actually there is Rudy News. First of
all, over the last couple of days, news broke
that Rudy Giuliani this is amazing. Rudy Giuliani
tried to get actor Sacha Baron Cohen arrested
for extortion over the entire Borat to fiasco
with Maria Baykal over that we now know about.
Rudy was suspended from YouTube over election
fraud or fraud. He may be back on YouTube now.
I'm not I'm not totally sure. But at one point he
was suspended and I actually saw clips during that
suspension of Rudy. I guess the clips must have
been on some other platform, not YouTube. Rudy
still talking as recently as about seven to 10
days ago about the election being stolen from him
by by Joe Biden, stolen from Trump, by Joe Biden.
And there is reportedly a criminal investigation
going on into Rudy Giuliani. So that's the latest
with Rudy Giuliani on today's bonus show. We are
going to talk about Miami Beach declaring a state
of emergency over the absolute insanity of spring
break crowds that have flocked there because it's
been promoted as just being wide open. It's covid
freedom as framed by many. And we're going to
talk about this on the bonus show. And it's
particularly funny because as many of you know,
we're going to be on the show taking a week off
next week. And I was actually being fully
vaccinated myself. I was actually thinking
with my girlfriend of driving to a beach somewhere
and, you know, maybe South Carolina. But South
Carolina is not really that warm yet in in March,
maybe Florida. I love Miami Beach. And then I saw
it's spring break. Hell, it's covid. Hell, it's
absolutely nuts. So we decided to go somewhere
else. I'm going to be going somewhere else. But
it's going to be a place that requires testing,
for example, to go and this type of thing. And
so I tweeted about this over the weekend saying,
I'm really glad I made the decision not to go
there and some blue checkmark right winger.
I didn't even know who he was. But you can
you'll find this if you look at my Twitter,
sort of like tweeted an attack on me saying you're
vaccinated and you're still so afraid of something
that even for unvaccinated people has like a one
percent death rate that you're still not coming
down to Florida. And within like minutes of that
tweet, Florida declared a state of Miami Beach,
declared a state of emergency and a curfew. So,
yes, it's less about will I as a vaccinated person
get sick on the beaches of Miami? It's more about
it doesn't sound fun. I don't want to go and be in
a curfew situation with all sorts of unvaccinated,
untested people going completely crazy. Now,
that that's not interesting to me. And I felt like
instant. Vindicated by my choice as Miami Beach is
now in a state of emergency. We will talk about
that on the bonus show. That's a big lead up.
We also will talk about the Biden White House
staff cannabis policy, which just led to
some people being let go. And we will
have more about this entire Putin Biden
debate idea with Biden calling Putin a killer
and the coverage that it's received. We will
also talk about that and more on today's bonus
show. How do you get access to the bonus show?
It's very easy. You sign up at
join Pakman Dotcom. That's it.
We have an unpublished new secret coupon code,
I'm telling you, but no one else. That code is
immoral. 21, all one word, all lowercase. It's
an immorally cheap discount. I might regret it
a year from now. I might look back and say, that
was disgusting when I offered that coupon code.
You can also simply become a patron on Patreon
at at least the five dollar a month level.
Patreon dot dotcom slash David Pakman show.
All right, I'll see everybody on the bonus show
and then tomorrow. We're here this week.
We're off next week. And then we'll be back.